did you get I'm asking did you get the
same gift from Tom Hanks at the end okay
listen I was so happy you didn't know
what about like a writing like something
to ride a horse or tobacco Matthew and
Susan were both telling us that you gave
the most awesome rap gift like they were
like it's so beautiful it's leather it's
inscribed it's like so yes and they were
like we just don't know it's when you
show up to work on a movie you have the
copy of the the pages that yours they're
called sighs yeah this the script pages
that you're shooting that day and the
call sheets so everybody knows exactly
what you're doing
they are leather holders for those sides
and this little pen and you can keep you
know it's on I've used it on complicated
days and you because you need to know
and the fact that neither Susan nor
Matthew knew what they were like it's so
beautiful but she even said this is a
coin purse I don't care no but it was
funny though because then and they're
gonna figure it out then it makes
perfect sense it's the most perfect wrap
it you're too beautiful now they know
now the more you know yeah so take
Michelle take it out of its shrink wrap
and use the damn thing
I will not stop talking until you
subscribe to my youtube channel that's
right and I could talk a lot seriously
not gonna stop yep still here not going
anywhere I see you don't walk away from
this